من موازات سخرت صحف لبنانيه من عرض متجدد
لوزير الخارجيه الايراني بمساعده لبنان في
مجال الطاقه واضافات انه كاسابقاته من
المرات لا ينطوي الا على رسائل فالمساعدات
الاقتصاديه الايرانيه الموعوده لم يتلقاها
لبنان ابدا وبحسب صحف محليه فان ايران غير
قادره على مساعده نفسها لتنهال على لبنان
بعروض تامين السيول والمحروقات لتشغيل
معامل الانتاج الطاقه والموجوده واستحداث
معمالين اضافيين حيث تعاني ايران مشاهدينا
حاليا من استمرار ازمه الطاقه وتحديداس
اكثر من نصف المدن باتت في حاله شبه اغلاق
بينها مازن تران واصفهان وقزويان والبس
دوائر حكوميه ومدارس وجامعات مغلقه تماما
وايضا المخابز بعضها توقف عن العمل بسبب
نقص الغاز كما اكدت تقارير متداوله انقطاع
الغاز في المنازل وانقطاع الكهرباء واغلاق
محطات الوقود لنقص في ماده البنزين تحديدا
[موسيقى]
ستشوارئ